it's really funny this this conference
is very interesting I've been
interesting story to tell I'm really
humbled really to be here
rails comp Chicago was the first one
right was the first conference I ever
paid for but I didn't go my lead
developer Eric Kastner wanted to go so
bad so bad I was like [ __ ] I have to
send him so he went and had a great time
and anybody's on Twitter right now
please hit up at castor and tell him I
want to kiss his face cuz he's such a
wonderful dude yeah he's a good dude
his beard anyway um yeah this community
is kind of near and dear to my heart you
know I know that you guys bring out
speakers sometimes that from the outside
I know they spoke in here and I know I
think Ferris might have spoke here last
year and different different things of
that nature so you know I can't develop
[ __ ] like I can't do that that's not
really what I know but what's
interesting is that out of all the
platforms this one kind of hits a very
deep and soft spot in my heart real
quick before I go into that because I
just want to paint the context for you
how many of you know who I am or some
what about me raise your hand how many
don't devastating now but actually I
kind of figured that was the case
I've been lucky I've been speaking a lot
of places where I haven't had to give
the history lesson I apologize for
something you don't know it but I'll
just give you three minutes of where I
come from so you understand why I'm
standing here and then I'll get into my
spiel and also more importantly I have
no interest in standing up here and
bragging about what I've done I'd much
rather do QA so I know it's like the end
and I know you gotta get up and get in
line but it would mean so much to me and
I was talking to Chad
Chad's giving $200 cash to anybody who
asks a question while I'm up here son
they say man you are so awesome let's
hear for Chuck not you
you're the best [ __ ] dude ever
absolutely I was born in Belarus in the
former Soviet Union and I came here in
1978 when I was three we were very poor
my dad had a great uncle who was kind of
kind of take care of us but it took nine
months to get from former Soviet to the
US all the paperwork and the [ __ ]
retina scan all that so we had to stay
in Italy for six months while our visas
got processed and while we were there
this great uncle passed away so now we
come to America it's the next generation
under him which is like my dad's second
cousin removed all that horseshit and
you know we're like the long-lost
relatives from Russia we show up and
were like hey we're here they had very
little interest seeing our faces but
they were they were good and they kind
of helped out as much as they could but
we moved into a studio apartment in
Queens and 78 literally literally
slightly smaller than this stage and I
lived with eight of my family members
and it was pretty ghetto and old school
and it was tough it was super tough but
my dad got a job at a liquor store in
Clark New Jersey and he lived in Queens
and I still bust my dad's chops because
I say that he spent more money on gas
that he did actually getting paid but we
kind of saved up did our thing my dad
eventually became the manager of that
store we moved to the dirty jurors as I
like to call it Edison New Jersey and
and you know he became eventually the
manager we saved every dollar didn't buy
anything and eventually he became part
owner and that's kind of how this all
started I on the other hand was
outrageously entrepreneurial when I was
six I had seven lemonade stands my
friends ran them I was not going to be a
cashier I was marketing
I always say you know I talk a lot about
television in the web and I always say
we're in the eyeballs and ears business
so I was like we're in the eyeballs
business and it hit me I forgot this I
was trying to remember what I did when
all my friends were tied up running
lemonade stands and I remembered that
I'd made all the signs and really wildly
I used to walk on the streets that the
cars were not industry I'm a sidewalk
and try to figure out where literally I
would sit like on a grassy knoll and
just watch every single person driving
space and try to figure out where their
eyes went so I knew which tree or a pole
to put the sign on so I've always been
outrageously interested in like habits
so the lemonade thing did really well
but then I really blew the [ __ ] up in
eighth grade when I started a baseball
card business and I completely dominated
I was making like 1,500 to 2,000 dollars
a weekend selling baseball cards and
amol of of New Jersey which when you're
13 and you have six G's you know under
your bed you know and you're not selling
weed you're doing awesome so so that was
awesome and I was crushing it on crap I
told that bingo guy wouldn't say it once
Bob so pissed that I definitely will say
especially since we're in Baltimore when
they kick the Ravens ass in the first
game of the year this year but we stole
all your [ __ ] right sorry getting nerdy
with jets I apologize anyway then my dad
ruined my life I was doing all this
stuff it was awesome and at 14 first
generation immigrant oldest son pops
drags my ass into the liquor store and
pays me two bucks an hour to bag ice for
ten hours a day in the basement that
blew and you know I mean I was making 20
bucks a day instead of making two jeez I
was either in the mall with my friends
and girls and being a boss and some
Frank Thomas rookie cards like it was my
job or I was in the basement like I was
[ __ ] sloth from the Goonies bagging
ice
hey you guys I'm in terrible so finally
at 16 though I was able to come upstairs
and my life changed very very quickly
after bagging ice and you know dusting
shelves there was one very famous day
where every customer and Wine Library at
the time called shoppers discount
liquors was in the Short Hills Milburn
area of New Jersey so it was an affluent
area but we were very much a liquor and
beer store but literally all I would say
40 people came in that day asking for
camus special select 1990 Cabernet and
finally like the 17th person I was like
dude you know I'm gonna take a back
water we didn't have back orders but I
was like [ __ ] this I'm taking one so I
was like I'll take a back order you know
what's your name what your address how
much wine do you want he's like well
I'll take four cases I'm like [ __ ] this
guy's an alcoholic this was a lot and I
was like poor cases are you having a
party and he was like no no I collect
wine and literally literally guys at
that exact moment I was like cuz I
wanted to help my family business cuz
like any punk kid entrepreneur 16 years
old I thought everything my dad was
doing was wrong but it was so boring I
wasn't a normal high school kid I didn't
give a crap about drinking beer liquor
or Zima which was ripping hot at the
time and pop that Jolly Rancher in there
umm right so the wine thing was
interesting right at that moment as I
collect wine I was like [ __ ] Gretzky
Michael Jordan Frank Thomas Opus one
silver oak Saint [ __ ] I can do this and
so literally that's what attached me
that people collected wine so literally
right there in the middle of store when
I was 16 I was like I'm gonna be the
greatest wine guy of all time that's
literally what I want to do for my life
that's it cuz school sucks [ __ ] that and
this is what I'm gonna do so I started
reading about wine in insane level and
even though my parents are Eastern
European we owned a liquor store they
would not let me drink anything so I
read for five years knew all this stuff
launched winelibrary.com I wanted to
change the name of our business I hated
shoppers discount liquors we were part
of a co-op even though we were all
separate stores so everybody had
different type of stores I felt that our
brand was getting hurt by other stores
that sucked so the web was my outlet you
know 97 I launched
library calm and and that's kind of
where it started from 1998 to 2005 when
I ran wine library day-to-day in that
seven-year window
I grew our family business from a three
to a sixty million dollar a year
business so that was good and family was
happy and things were great in 2001 I
met Eric Cashner which is pretty much
brings me into this world I decide you I
wish you guys could you think some
videos are out there funny I wish I
taped the conversation between my dad
and I when I tried to convince him to
hire Eric that we a liquor store needed
a full-time developer that was some
funny [ __ ] that you would have liked
with my dad's break broken English with
no [ __ ] way I'm like dad I will give
up all my salary to hire him because I
knew I knew this was where it was going
I was pumped about it Eric came on board
which was great and you know that
started even the first day was awesome I
think it was a was actually right after
September 11 so he started full full
time in 2002 first day walks in I'm
searching Yahoo he's like dude check out
this Google thing all right typed in
Google Mike Eric this is so stupid how
are they gonna make money it's a blank
[ __ ] page idiots
that was me you know now that I predict
things in social comment a time like who
thank God those early first four or five
years I wasn't taping I'd be long gone
you would have loved my doozy on how
frugal was gonna change the world I put
my library's entire business model by
the way on frugal and now finally red
lasers here it's like a decade later but
it's still not really where I think it
will be anyway so Eric comes learn all
this stuff and you know we we grow Wine
Library I start hearing about all these
different names blogging all that stuff
and and then I turned 30 in 2005 and I'm
driving from Manhattan to New Jersey
which is where Wine Library is and
somewhere around the New Jersey Turnpike
I decided that for the first time ever
in my life I wasn't 100% happy I was
like 97 and what I realized was this
Wine Library is not as big as it could
be because I can't ship to Boston I
can't ship to Maryland
I can't ship to mass all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] liquor laws in our country
yeah clap that [ __ ] up [ __ ]
sounds like [ __ ] this should have been
like you know way bigger I'm losing my
prime years I'm 30 now it can't be
bullshitting I got I want to buy the New
York Jets there's no way I'm getting to
a billion selling wine so I got to do
something about it so I decided I
Roenick Lee right in that moment that
was the summer when Eric and now we had
a couple other developers all they did
was watches a Frank and I looked at
today and I was like I could do that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know and so they're
like no you can't seize the [ __ ] I'm
like [ __ ] those Ducks I was like I'm
gonna do this so and say is the best
and so I I decided that I was going to
start a wine show I was gonna go super
narrow so I launched Wine Library TV in
February 2006 and the first month I did
Wine Library TV full month March of 2006
was the first time in 96 straight months
that Wine Library did not grow 20
percent against the year before sales
the first time from the day I took over
operations we grew at least 20 percent
or more usually 40 or 50 compared to the
year before his numbers for that month
and that kind of was a culture shock in
my building and that continued I hustled
WL TV for 18 months without giving a
[ __ ] about anything I did it every day
taped at 30 minutes a day and more
importantly spent 15 hours a day going
to wine blogs and forums and talking
about what I gave a [ __ ] about because
the happiness was so much dramatically
more important to me than what was
happening with dollars and cents
everybody in the building thought I lost
my [ __ ] mind but I was so ridiculously
happy being in the community of what I
loved and so that was really exciting
for me that was a great great time then
Time magazine wrote a piece excuse me
New York magazine wrote a piece that led
to Joel Stein from Time magazine saying
it wrote an amazing piece that led to
the Conan O'Brien producers finding out
about me emailed me I thought it was my
friends playing a joke I mean they're
like we want you on Conan and I was like
sure went on there
we ate dirt grass millions of people saw
it that's when the web started really
seeing what I was doing and it kind of
took off from there you know just in the
hot you know next day I got all these
you know Hollywood agencies wanting to
sign me I signed with CAA so I'm repping
same people that rep Oprah and Beckham
and Derek Jeter it's some crazy-ass [ __ ]
and so that went well and I've been
pitched a lot of TV but then what
started happening in the height of all
this I wanted to talk about the other
thing and probably what I wanted to
spend the rest of time talking with you
guys about this
I just love business and marketing and
building things I love and supporting
them and the communities behind it so I
started blogging under my own name
garyvaynerchuk.com right in the height
of all my wine madness just talking
about some of the things I see the
trends things I believe in and that led
to a lot of opportunity I've spoken a
lot of conferences and I wrote a book
last year called crushing and did really
really well and I'm writing a new book
right now and I kind of want to talk a
little bit about that and I want to give
2qa called the Thank You economy the new
book I'm writing called the Thank You
economy is really taking a look at you
know customer service you know the
social media debate you know it's so
funny to me
I started a consulting company last year
somebody might know called vaynermedia
with my brother AJ and all my friends
are like what the [ __ ] is he doing you
know it's not a scalable product kind of
weird left turn for him but I think a
lot of people in this space and just in
business in general really lack
understanding that we're all running a
marathon there almost everybody I see in
in the web space so many people are all
running sprints it's like every buddies
running a company like they're a 19 year
old dude all they want to do is close
fast which is interesting and I agree
thank you for that one clap I meant a
lot to me I'm serious
because it's serious because I'm dead
serious this [ __ ] is so obnoxiously
early I mean YouTube just celebrated its
fifth birthday I mean the consumer
internet that we're all built [ __ ]
Twitter and Facebook and all the other
thing the building on the web or
whatever the consumer web or whatever
you want to call it the Internet I
always get yelled at for this stuff but
whatever it is it's only been 15 16
years since AOL spammed our actual
mailboxes trying to get us online I mean
the [ __ ] Internet hasn't had sex yet
and it's dominating
I mean this is ridiculously early I
really hope that we're painting that
context here this stuff is crazy early
this is just starting and the problem is
everybody just wants to sell and close
and nobody's paying attention to
building long-term real relationships
when we all look back at the Zappos
acquisition by Amazon everybody's gonna
recognize how ridiculously smart bezos's
they [ __ ] stole Zappos at 1.3 billion
I know a lot of people that thought that
it was a you know a ridiculous thing to
pay for a shoe company they were out
selling Amazon on certain products when
they were more expensive they were
beating them on culture we buy for
different reasons today things are
shifting and that convenience is
obviously dramatically important to us
but giving a [ __ ] is coming on strong
and the fact of the matter is you like
that yeah
should I change the title to the giving
a [ __ ] economy this is a good test case
yeah
HarperCollins will kick my face in will
try to see what they say it's really
coming guys listen we are living in the
first time ever where you can scale your
caring the fact that I'm interacting
with people that give a crap about what
I do while I'm taking a [ __ ] the 3
o'clock in the morning on my laptop is
amazing I mean this I mean you know we
work you like that Thanks
I'm gonna use that one again got it um I
I just really think it's fascinating
like I'm one dude and yes I am
outrageous energy and yes I'm
ridiculously handsome and charismatic I
get it but but it's so fascinating AJ
and I consult for the National Hockey
League Campbell's Cadbury the Jets it's
an inside thing I'm trying to figure how
to buy him you know and a lot of big
companies and they always tell me like
how do we how do we you know I'm like so
I come in I'm like listen here's the a
trillion conversations going around your
brand right now on Twitter on Facebook
whatever other platforms tumblr whatever
it may be I'm like you need to
conversate this is happening with or
without you get in there become part of
this and not just putting out fires it
is time for our entire space to stop
using these platforms just to put out
fires how about saying thank you how
about when somebody's giving you daps
that you like pat him on the ass
virtually you know like you know how
about that I mean it is an absolute
dream for businesses a lot of what I've
always loved about this space in a big
way is yes I'm not a developer but a lot
of the people and I know a lot of people
in this room you are but I also know
that a lot of people are building
products building small businesses
there's an always been a really
fascinating passionate entrepreneurial
vibe to this space to me and so the fact
that people talk about your products
that is so important I mean I listen to
people say well I don't have enough
scale yet if one person follows you and
gives a crap about what you say you
should be ridiculously thankful I'm
serious I mean that is right I mean
that's incredible I'm blown away that
850,000 people follow me on Twitter and
give a crap enough that that freaks with
my brain on such a level like you I'm so
grateful so grateful and companies and
people need to start getting grateful
not chasing [ __ ] numbers and while
I'm on this kick if you allow me for two
seconds I really just want to riff on
one thing
can we please collectively as a space
punch the people directly in their
[ __ ] mouths when they say things like
if I get a hundred more followers I'll
donate $100 to Haiti hey [ __ ] just
donate $100 to 80 and you guys and you
guys code and [ __ ] I can only just go at
them one by one
I don't know how to scale and just say
[ __ ] you so please if you see those guys
make some coach tits to happen like put
some JSON and some html5 on their asses
and [ __ ] with them please [ __ ] I hate
that you don't have say I don't know I'm
going to a weird direction I apologize
these [ __ ] Facebook privacy peeps
listen I respect privacy and all that
but you know what I'm really pissed at
the 800 people I saw for the last month
try to game the Facebook situation and
say I'm quitting Facebook and here's my
page four and here's my blog post the
only reason they did that was to get
exposure to leverage the story and hope
they might get an article in The Wall
Street Journal or Newsweek or something
like that because I'll tell you right
now of the 800 and I marked them all
down as I saw it and put him a nice
little bucket on the left side seven
hundred ninety nine of them are using
Facebook right now so they're full of
[ __ ] [ __ ] and more importantly what I
think people need to recognize is
everything you're doing is being
documented my great-great grandkids are
watching this right now hey Jeremiah I
think you have my DNA please if I didn't
buy the Jets please execute that for me
thank you the fact that that just
happened and the best part is my
great-great grandson or daughters give
me like my name's not [ __ ] Jeremiah
I'm not a [ __ ] note Radames I'm sorry
but everything you do every way you
interact with every customer every
product you build everybody you retweet
everybody you support everybody you're
giving a quote to for their book the
foreword anybody and everything you're
doing in today's world is being
documented and you are writing your
legacy right now so please to not
embarrass yourself in your future family
give some thought to the dumb gaming
[ __ ] like that hundred dollar Haiti
thing or when you want to play the
Facebook card because you want to get
some attention for 40 seconds and then
you're a hypocrite 13 minutes later
think about what you're doing because I
promise you right now there's probably
about 13 to 15 people and I'm not
exaggerating number that's the right
number right now I don't think they're
bad people but I definitely think
differently of them you know I think
like you're just you know it's all
short-term and so I think you know I'm
just so fascinated by this world we live
in now that where I feel like the truth
is undefeated you know like it's just
getting real hard to hide you know it's
getting you know look at the new iPhone
so you go to Vegas like maybe you did
for rails comp the other year right and
you know you call your girlfriend like
yeah baby I'm just playing werewolf
after rails comp she's like yeah I put
on your iChat oh [ __ ] Spearmint Rhino I
mean you know you know you can't hide
anymore the world is changing and I
think we have to really adjust to the
real reality of our world and I for one
and thrilled with that because listen
I'm very aware of my DNA I am absolutely
positive that people in this crowd right
now before this talk and maybe after
this talk think I'm a douchebag or I'm
too over-the-top or I'm full of [ __ ] or
it's too much self-promotion I get all
that I respect it to no end
I'm very self-aware I've got East Coast
flavor for East Coast people its
intensity I get you like that oh this is
going over better and I thought thank
you like I I get it and you know what I
respect it I interact you know the 27
negative reviews I have on Amazon every
one of those people have gotten a
response and I appreciate it I get it we
need to respect each other's thoughts we
do you have to become more self-aware as
we have to become more self-aware as
people and we definitely have to become
self-aware about our products because a
lot of our products have
and there's things that you know we need
to fix and I think this combative nature
or going like this well that's good is
it's not going to help anybody and I
think we need to really respect and
understand that that's just the way it's
gonna be and I think it lends itself to
a very very good situation long term I'm
excited about it I know at the end of
the day one by one until I [ __ ] die I
will scale every relationship I can and
communicate with people as much as I can
respect their thoughts on me and I know
it works because if you can show people
who you are if you can actually give a
crap enough this economy of I know
people who are like yeah it's so weird
who you somebody something email
yesterday's like Gary I was analyzing
how you use Twitter it's like it's weird
you know I only reply to people that
have a thousand followers or more you
replying to people that have like three
and [ __ ] like what's the strategy I'm
like so my reply was like dear Tim
here's a strategy you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and I'm a good guy that was really the
answer he wrote back I'm this is true
they wrote back no seriously and I wrote
back no [ __ ] seriously
I was like dick you know there was sorry
I mean hold on
Who am I talk to outside they said I
wasn't gonna curse are you in here
didn't work out yeah man sorry we don't
live in do you know who I feel bad for I
feel bad for every one of us in here
our version who was us two generations
ago that didn't have the freedom to
build the kind of things we want the
people that couldn't you know you know
practicality is something I believe in
so much you know this isn't any like
secret [ __ ] I don't believe like you
think it's gonna happen and it happens I
mean you've got to work your face off
it's all about the hustle the fact that
we can work our 9 to 5 so our 9 to 7
come home you know hang out a little bit
with our families and then work you know
from 11:00 p.m. to 3:00 in the morning
building the [ __ ] we love it's such a
special thing and I feel awful for every
entrepreneur or engineer that came
before us because what we're living
through right now is ridiculously
awesome and we should be ridiculously
thankful for it and our awareness about
this I think is very much under the
radar I come from a place and man I'll
tell you right now people always ask me
like dude what are you like a cokehead
or a Red Bull
why would you have so much energy I'm
like I am so over-the-top
driven by gratitude the amount of
self-esteem that my mom put in my body
should be legal the fact that my dad at
14 years old taught me that saved my ass
because you know I'm a storyteller
schmoozer kind of character I would have
liked to fudge numbers and things like
that now it saves me in this very
transparent world and that combo
appearance that were very different has
allowed me an amazing opportunity the
love they gave me the opportunity they
gave me and the fact that I was born in
a very bad place Belarus is still the
worst of the former Soviet Union's they
have dictatorship I can't go back to
where I was born because they Boogle
everybody and I'm an idiot and throw out
all these numbers and they would've
figured out I kidnap my ass I'd be done
I mean I can't go there we are so lucky
to be here and to be living during this
platform shift this is the greatest
culture shift of our
we don't this is I'm promising you
we are dramatically under estimating
what's happening right now
the opportunity we have and how we're
going about doing this and the barriers
that are being broken the gatekeepers
controlled the game forever
guys I have been offered 40 television
shows why because I at my home well at
Wine Library which was my home was able
to tape a show using a $500 camera now
it could be even less than that and
putting it on a service that allowed it
to be free youtube and then viddler and
was able to go through all the
gatekeepers know dick face in LA decided
that i had the goods I didn't have to
move to California which I never would
have done because I love my family too
much and yet because the gatekeepers
have lost the keys I was able to go
direct-to-consumer build brand equity
and build every opportunity that I have
today which are massive and make me
happy as [ __ ] and the fact of the matter
is I'm not as special as some may think
every single person here has that
playing field and that is the luckiest
thing that has ever happened period
you guys talk too much in the beginning
you cut into my [ __ ] time
hey so a couple other things I want to
talk about while while we're we're all
here and hanging out a couple trends
that I'm really passionate about one
I've been thinking a lot about freemium
lately right I mean this is a
conversation this is nothing new but
here's the difference I think if you're
building products I hope that you're
debating freemium in a very substantial
way because I think that Apple has
fundamentally created a unique
opportunity for us I think because of
the app culture we are now seeing a huge
push towards people accepting paying
three bucks four bucks seven bucks and
I'm very fascinated by the consumers
that you know all I really think about
is culture and ships and these kind of
things and I think right now we're at
the beginning of a real opportunity to
really monetize building platforms
products small aspects because people
are buying these apps and we're not as
comfortable necessarily maybe buying
them from a website though smart people
like DHH and freed and those guys have
been long playing this game and many
other people have I think right now
there is a substantial culture shift
that is a much bigger wave to people
paying for product and I hope that
people are looking at what's going on
with these apps especially with the iPad
because the iPad feels a whole lot more
like a computer to the normal consumer
than an iPhone and so this app culture
is a humongous positive for this global
space and I'd like you to give it some
thought the other thing that I'm really
by the way I want to get into Q&A now so
if you're interested in asking a
question about anything I talked about
or anything else please line up now 200
bones
the other thing I want to talk about are
you guys gonna be ridiculously
over-the-top lazy and not ask questions
thank you so much um I'll get to in a
minute
I'm from actually you know what [ __ ]
that go ahead customer service baby this
is awesome
thank you thanks great run Ronnie run
run I like Ronnie Ronnie's good you my
man Ronnie could you explain what you
meant by what you were you basically
saying that freemium is bogus or you
know we need to charge money tie it all
in together
yeah sure I'm sorry if I didn't paint it
clearly thanks for coming to the talk
guys that are leaving stay well bye
darling um no I think freemium was huge
I think you get them in you let him try
it whether it's trial or you have you
know a certain amount you can do a
certain amount of it listen guys let's
open up the debate it'd be really
interesting if Twitter you know launched
under this kind of umbrella if you
remember oh six of lato five it was free
24/7 365 not just the way it was it'd be
really fascinating to me to see if
Twitter said you will you can have 400
friends for free but it's nine bucks a
year if you want more really cured now
that ship has sailed and a lot of people
are sitting right now saying I wouldn't
have paid it or maybe you're saying you
would have paid it I'm not quite sure
it's tough for you answer properly
because the context has already been set
and you've already used it under
preconceived notions but what would
Twitter look like today if they were
making nine bucks per user of everybody
who has more than 400 fans I think
they'd be a little bit more viable of
business I still think there's other
ways and I understand that the hockey
stick growth might have not happened as
easily and I can I remember Jai qu and
and pound Sandra's other competitors I
get it I remember but you know I think
it should be debated and I think right
now more so I think what 37's did was
harder because there was such a culture
of free I think the apps right now see
here's the thing I get out of inside
baseball way too many people in our
space are so inside baseball we all live
in our [ __ ] bubble I like to talk to
people that have no [ __ ] idea what
Foursquare Gowalla
is you know and I think that they're
interesting to me because they are now
being trained the masses not being 87 of
us I'm talking the rest of the [ __ ]
thing
they're being trained to pay for [ __ ]
and I think it's our time to strike
hey thanks a lot I love you Ronnie
hey Mia hey what's your name my name is
Tamara Cameron no it's like hammer with
a team hammer take Tamara gotta [ __ ] my
clothes pretty loud so when you're
talking about larger companies engaging
with all the conversations that are
going on yes mutti how do you tell them
to do this and still maintain honesty
and sincerity and that's where they do
you even think that's possible that's a
really good question dude so I'm gonna
go over to rail-to-rail Scott
most companies right now bro the
answer's no you know why cuz they're
[ __ ] you know all they really care
about is bottom line and ROI and it's
been stunning to me going into the
corporate world how little emotion or
giving any kind of crap to the consumer
there really is it's even worse than I
think we think right that being said you
have breakthroughs you have companies
I've been blown away by Campbell's this
hundred plus year iconic you know old
sky mean they're [ __ ] old school you
know can you edit that imma get in
trouble and so they um they want to go
there like you know it's it's really
gonna always be the DNA of the CEO it's
just the way it is it trickles down from
the top
you know if everybody's scared that the
CEOs numbers driven then that's what its
gonna be and they're gonna try to run
the [ __ ] sprint and they're not
gonna really give a [ __ ] about how your
day is they're saying hello to you
because they want us to sell you a
coupon on the back end but if you could
ever god forbid get there if you could
ever it's all culture it's all [ __ ]
cold the only thing it is is culture you
know what I mean you have to mean it
what I'm saying yo what's up or when I'm
just searching listen I spent my life on
some I remember some eyes you know which
Twitter bought and now is their back end
all I did all day was search Chardonnay
Merlot cab franck and when I would see
somebody say you know what Zinn should I
have tonight I wouldn't I look at I'd
click them and see where they lived
I didn't say
you should have you know Turley's in and
ironically I just did a show on it
here's the link I literally looked to
where they live and because I understood
every store in the country and though I
know Wine Library beat the [ __ ] out of
all of them I would say to them listen
from a convenience standpoint you live
not far from K&L wines you should go
there and ask for you know Raffin Ali
Martinelli and Turley right that's real
[ __ ] now then hopefully that honest from
the heart engagement led to them
clicking my profile they click it they
get to Wine Library TV you have to have
your home
[ __ ] this microblogging [ __ ] you
have to have a home right they went
there and then God forbid if my content
was good enough because at the end of
the day I don't give a [ __ ] what kind of
marketing play you have content is
always king right if my [ __ ] was good
enough no matter how nice I was when
they click to Wine Library TV I didn't
know what I was talking about and it
wasn't entertaining for them that may be
gone right but if I was strong if it was
good then they would and that's how I
built my business and my brand because I
knew that I was giving a great product
and I knew that my 14 hours of sweat one
by one cuz the remember this is O six
Twitter was nothing it was so small is
getting little from that I had a B in
wine forums in wine bunch I couldn't go
to Facebook because I didn't want to be
the creepy old guy peddling wine to the
kids because it was still kind of
college you know so it was hard I
punched these marketers in the face and
these meetings cuz I'm like it's so easy
for you now and [ __ ] you're a logo
so we can scale this let's hire 800
people to be behind this you know
instead of buying $40,000 billboards
that don't mean dick cuz I don't know if
you guys are watching I don't know if
you drive but I'll tell you right now
I'm not a big fan of traditional media
and a lot of ways to begin with pricing
wise but anybody who's buying outdoor
media needs to look inside their head
because if you look at any dry I'm
scared to drive right now they're not
looking at the billboard they're not
even looking at the [ __ ] Road they're
Texan
I'm scared out there so you know there's
so much [ __ ] I want to talk about like
now what I want to do but I want to
answer more questions cuz I don't that
much time but then like I want to get
into the ROI discussion you know there's
like what's the ROI and social media
well I don't know [ __ ] what's the
ROI and having a real relationship mean
while you're paying for billboards that
have 40,000 cars drive by and you're
paying a price on that meanwhile
nobody's looking at it but you're paying
or when you buy a magazine ad really cuz
you're paying 1.3 million circulation
that's what you're getting paid for
that's your [ __ ] impression price well
guess what how do I know if somebody's
going to page 60 [ __ ] 7 and seeing my
ad I don't and don't even get me started
a [ __ ] Nielsen's it's a box in every
4200 homes that's horseshit so I want to
know what your name Rick what's up brick
so I first saw you at a fella yeah well
yours back thanks man um and I really
like you're passionate about you know
getting rid of this whole corporate
[ __ ] and like you know thinking this
hold me tell you thinking of the
customer is like a number and you know
how are you gonna you know it's coming
Louise it out you know it's coming
whether I talk about or not because the
fact of matter is this platform is just
exposing everything and it's just a
matter of time today so so what's what's
why do you think it's gonna be you know
like how do you see you know all what
we're doing cuz a lot of people in this
room are responsible you know it's great
to be a part of this because they're
responsible for helping you know the
people with the ideas and the people who
really want to connect with our
customers to really do it you know yeah
so where do you see it in like a couple
years and well I think it's like
everything else right like the reason I
believe in all this so much is we've
just lived through the big box store era
right like if you study business it's
always this you know you build up
pushback counterculture we're going
through a huge age of information right
now right well guess what's coming next
restrictions if you're in the filtering
and restriction and aggregating business
you're gonna do quite well right because
that's just the yin and the yang you
know I'm bullish on privacy you know
like that's just the way [ __ ] goes you
just go countercultural we just lived
through the big box retail era we just
we're living through a great golden
Europe for Amazon here's what I know
it's gonna push back to the mom-and-pop
mentality it makes my heart sing like
what is it singing like Milli Vanilli my
heart is singing no
vanilla right now blame it on the rain
you know why cuz the rain don't mind but
I'm the rain don't care but anyway my
heart is singing because I know the I
said the other day and it's really stuck
in my head I almost decided almost made
it the subtitle of the Thank You economy
I literally believe that your
grandparents and your great-grandparents
right now are more positioned are more
properly positioned to be successful in
2012 and beyond than we are because the
way they built their businesses was they
gave a [ __ ] that's how we have a baker's
dozen
they gave 13 go to [ __ ] Whole Foods
and pick up 13 Donuts tell me if they're
gonna charge you for 12 they're not and
they cared you know why because they
lived under small-town rules whenever
you know the old mom-and-pop game you
had to do the right thing as the butcher
because if mrs. sally Sanderson had a
bad experience she was telling everybody
else and it was all localized then we
got fragmented well all this [ __ ] all
you [ __ ] you guys are so [ __ ]
smart and building all this awesome [ __ ]
do you know what you're doing you're
bringing us back to small town rules we
are going to the golden year of small
town rules because we're more connected
than ever we have more relationships
word of mouth is on [ __ ] steroids
it's Barry Bonds it's Roger Clemens it's
all that and and that changes the
complete dynamic a branding brand
perception look at what happened with
that 18 t dude right he calls you know
he emails the CEO they give him the
cease and desist he puts out the
voicemail out there and everybody jumps
on and 18 he's like oh [ __ ] you know I
mean this is gonna happen a lot
meanwhile I love transparency you know
why look at the perfect game in baseball
right the UMP blows the [ __ ] out of the
call right you know ten years ago he
would have had one quote in the paper he
would have had so little chance to
actually do anything meanwhile he did
all the right things and now it's become
a good thing because he did the right
thing you know he you know I I just I
find this amazing I think it's gonna go
he'll go far but then back to that point
cuz I thought that was a good one the
guy with the hammer but a DRT that guy
he's awesome
I gotta go apologize cuz it in catch it
I'm sorry man but that guy I think he's
going to an interesting point because
what I think is gonna happen is right
now it's gonna be not authentic so the
authentic people gonna win right the
authentic people will win everyone's
gonna go [ __ ] you got to be authentic
fine [ __ ] it so people become authentic
and then we'll have this huge wave of
like
when you check in to a stadium you get
800 deals and so then you'll go back the
other way it's literally the up and down
and as long as we recognize that you
want to be going in the other direction
that when everything's going this way
that you're going that way there's a lot
of victories in that especially and most
importantly if you're doing it from your
heart
not because it's a tactical move totally
by the way go dolphins [ __ ] that I feel
like the Ravens more than the Dolphins
hey bro hey Gary my name is Miles
I knew I was not gonna have any other
opportunity to thank you I just have a
little thing while ago you and Jason
freak did a thing where you if you
bought both your books yes you did a
three-hour thing so I did that I bought
me because I wanted the real Athens book
I guess this book I'm sorry but anyway I
ended up getting this book really I
ended up getting I really just like a
throw it right what's that you wanted
three hours of freedoms book I was kind
of like this [ __ ] it's like it was
like an infomercial it's like and if you
call now you'll get seven more knives I
was like the seven more knives
I respect that I'm sorry well no no I
respected both of those guys it
somatically smarter than me so you made
the right call
well what happened Gary is that you
spent a little bit of time with me
talking afterwards and I ended up
reading other day when we did the 3-hour
talk and unfree left and an I stayed on
for another hour and made fun of them
yeah I took what you said I read your
book I ended up starting a little
podcast called kotor path and recently i
couldn't make it to railsconf and i put
out just a little thing asking people if
they would support me and I ended up in
three days raising like 800 bucks to get
here so I got here based on the just the
amazingness of the Ruby community and it
really a lot of it came from you know
you just learning how to say thanks and
and I really really appreciate you kind
of putting me on that path because now
I've got to the little I want to write
each and every person who donated then
just a handwritten thank you the game so
you come up here for a sec yeah sure
I just wanna top that Cowboys at least
it's NFC it doesn't bothers me much good
so how do you get out on a side of
baseball how do you get outside of the
vicious cycle yeah you know I have a big
advantage I'm already naturally outside
of baseball right I built a big business
and you know I'm a Salesman like you
know ironically like ironically I'm
pretty like in the space I'm very
flattered for that especially people get
to know me right and it's so funny
because when I really got into space I
was so business II now like Castro's
like you're gonna [ __ ] be hated you
know he's like you know cuz because
that's where I come from but I think if
you're honest and you just tell it like
it is and you feel like I feel like I
feel like I started here in the space
you know it was very tea and rock
climbing you know six you know still is
a little bit but it's a little bit more
like this I think I came here you know
what I mean but just genetically I'm
outside of baseball it
I do a lot of things outside of baseball
for every conference and I go to the
meetups and I love all this stuff and I
nobody reads more hacker news than me
and I love all that stuff right I still
have a lot of friends that are very
outside the space you know I I'm I do
I'm you know first of all I'm gonna go
to jail very shortly literally I go to
Central Park in New York and like watch
like 13 year olds I know I'm going to
jail when I watch their habits you know
it's something I enjoy I love our
culture I love it with all my heart
right I hear Glee is starting to make
people pay attention then I [ __ ]
watch Glee until my face falls off right
you know like I want to know what makes
people tick and so it's something I
enjoy so much like literally what I want
to do is be outside of baseball and then
talk to our space because I think that's
a very positive way to look at it so I
think you have to make a conscious
effort you know and I think that people
need to think about some of their
outside interests and I think it's
awareness I think if you want to be
outside baseball when you're out there
in the world when you're at a baseball
game
you know just watch what people are
doing I mean you know it's very
fascinating so if you get dinged by
someone in the tech press do you just
just brush it off or try and talk to it
yes so you mean like razzed like if
Arrington is like yeah yeah I think that
I very much respect wipe listen I'm very
loud I think in sound bites
I often rarely show my cards you know I
talk very general when I do this you
know I don't believe so much and up here
but I'm very good at down here right you
know I think I think that um I think I
respect why people would think that I
get it and so when they do I have to
take that medicine but I also know that
who I am I know who my parents raised I
know who I want to be in this society
and I know that nobody and it's just the
way it is I don't care what you think
nobody is trying harder to scale every
relationship he or she has an
opportunity more than me I'm staying up
to 3 o'clock in the morning bleeding out
of my eyeballs answering email I came
down here just now on the Amtrak did
email came here talk little hug on my
way back answering email like that's
I want this I I love people so it was
built for me this is timing and so I
respect it I engage it
I love debating it because I know you
know I know where I come from and you
know it's fun because anybody could say
well he's this and he's that you know it
depends on where the conversation is but
I can always play a lot of good cards
right you know it's like jay-z said men
lie women line numbers don't lie
you know at the end of the day if you do
it you do it and in this new world for
every person that tweets tomorrow at
Gary Vee you've changed you think you're
a celebrity now you didn't respond to my
email 97 people come right behind that
and say he just emailed me five minutes
ago so the truth is undefeated okay
thanks
sure man you rocked extending the time
yes
appreciate it hi my name is Michael hey
Michael um I had no idea who you were
before this talk and it's had been
actually awesome listening to you thanks
man but I have a question you said
you're doing consulting for big firms
yes I've got this viewpoint that any
time a customer complains to me it's
like the most awesome gift they could
possibly give me because then it gives
me an ability to improve something that
I had no update no idea about you and I
should kiss
I don't want to cook I don't want to
talk [ __ ] but this side is dominating
your ass
alright go ahead so anyway I was like
can I tell you something funny
yeah I just told the client that has
been kind of doing their shits so right
for the last six months I walked in to
like they get me like once you know for
two hours a month kind of thing I walked
in and I said alright everything's going
great I really like it I can't believe
holy [ __ ] you guys have changed this is
great this is gonna be good you need to
keep pounding this let's now go into
other parts of the company create the
culture blah blah blah and I killer
eight great what should we do next
I'm like alright you ready for this I
wasn't joking I was like I think I want
to do something wrong on purpose so we
can say we're sorry
so like I'm with you man I like I
pitched I pitched the client to do
something wrong on purpose
nice that's how much I love you know
having the opportunity to address
something wrong
no no it wasn't thank God
yes I created the oil spill so my
question is how do you find that going
in there in like the big corporate
because there's this whole [ __ ] idea
if you have to manage complaints yeah a
different game you know why because
every CEO of every major company in the
world doesn't have a 20 year thought
process right the game is broken they
want to be there for three or four years
they need to keep the stock price at a
certain point cash out and be our so how
the [ __ ] do you expect them to build on
what I'm calling a relationship platform
you don't build real relationships in
two years this is all forever right
think about how you think about this
think about how you and I feel about
each other right now in comparison to an
hour ago right we've kissed you know I
do what I say one thing you and I feel
differently about each other deep when I
was in Chicago and I broke my iPhone and
DHH and freed and I went to the Apple
Store and why don't I put I got to spend
that quality our time and I felt
differently about him admiring his work
but I had that hour and then when I saw
him in the hall
I've already off a different level right
I already feel like you know the
emotions of that day which was so
awesome come in and it becomes this
whole thing when freed and I took a
flight back from Big Omaha the other day
you know we were basically making out in
the seats it was disgusting you know
that's how in love with him I am and so
you slip but then by the way by the way
I'm being a dick face right now dropping
rock star names [ __ ] those guys how
about us right the next time I see you
it's gonna be different thing I'm like
dude remember when we kissed in
Baltimore and everybody's really what
the [ __ ] and no one I couldn't have you
know so listen it's going difficult
because the corporate game is built not
to do this however I believe that I will
get lucky maybe probably not but either
you know probably not because you know
complier working consulting work is
difficult I did it for a very strong
purpose I very much believe that too
many people in the space don't do enough
things to learn I need to taste [ __ ] you
know how are you supposed to know unless
you taste it and I think a lot of people
in our space know what they're good at
but they stick to what they know and
they don't do things you know maybe you
should throw a lemonade stand
one Saturday you taste
for dynamics it's very funny what
happens and I wanted to understand
corporate DNA I want to understand the
you know brand managers I want us to
understand CMOS and so even though on
paper it looks silly and all my
intellectual big thinking friends and
I've all these big companies probably
looked at it like [ __ ] Gary made the
short play I made the right play
I'm telling you made the right play it's
not fun I feel like I'm rocky and got
the blog on my [ __ ] back and doing
the snow [ __ ] but I'm learning so much
remember the wheelbarrow you know I'm
talking about and so but I'm learning so
much and it's gonna allow me to power
broke and I'm bringing Campbell's you
know bringing Pepsi together with sticky
bits like I just did that's interesting
stuff for me that happened cuz of me
that feels good you know I feel like I'm
pushing the envelope and there's only
one way to do it you got to speak their
language and I wanted to taste that [ __ ]
I wanted to taste it whether its sour or
sweet I want to do it I want to get my
hands dirty I even tried to figure out
code but you guys are way too smart for
me thanks man great thank you my name is
Craig hey Craig first a comment I think
is reminds me some of what you're saying
the thinking of the native elders talked
about thinking down the seven
generations that's something I think
that we could probably learn about from
the Western culture you know what's
funny about that note I'm addicted to
old people as they like you should see
so I travel a lot hopefully less now I
have a one-year-old so I'm trying to cut
down just like one of my last talks
actually for a while but I switch seats
on airplanes all the time if somebody
looks like Yoda I'm sitting next to them
like like the amount of conversations
that I've had with 80 and 90 year old
strangers I guarantee is that the
tippy-top of the world right now you
know why they played the game and you
know what they pulled me every one of
them not one of them gave a [ __ ] how
much money they made whether they were
rich or poor every one of them says the
same [ __ ] Gary I wish I spent more time
with my family and I wish I did
something I loved and I don't understand
how we know this and these are the
people that played our game the real
game [ __ ] the [ __ ] the real game and
how we don't take that into account yeah
and the questionnaire issue and address
you're talking about the freemium model
now if you have like a community and you
have the paid and unpaid members and how
do you get and engage those were not the
paid members to not feel second-class or
secondary to the those who are paid
since they don't have access perhaps to
ever
and listen this comes down to the DNA of
the person whose platform is right I can
very much understand why somebody would
have a tough time between us I have I
mean I many times said to myself huh
a hundred thousand people a day watching
Wine Library TV 30 minutes a day you
know
I much wanted to be the first video
blogger to really go there and really
charge right really go to 99 cents a
month you know and then I was like well
but then you know I don't wanna go all
the way there so I'll go to that premium
I'll do Monday and Tuesday you know free
and then Wednesday Thursday and you have
all these internal debates inside here's
what I mean though
what makes right now different and why
I'm talking about it out loud not inside
myself like I've been for the last five
years is the cultures being formed
there's being a different acceptance to
actually paying for things and think
collectively when it's bigger than you
and it becomes the umbrella of the
culture it allows you to kind of go that
way a little bit easier and so that's
what's fascinating me directly to answer
that question I think you caught all
those relationships one by one you make
you know you've got to come from an
honest place nobody's ever been confused
I want to buy the New York Jets right
I'd love to think I could win that on
kissing dudes faces but I can't I need
to make a couple bucks and so you know
it's there's nothing wrong with building
a business and charging I know it's
difficult you know depending on your DNA
but I think when you're when you've
spent time building extra features or
whatever it may be or doing extra to
create this you know I think it's
acceptable especially and most
importantly if you respect listen and
care for the people that are not the
paying customers well thank you sure man
hey Gary I'm Edward hey Edward these
days and I could be met in Orlando and I
was like hey mobile payments are gonna
be the [ __ ] [ __ ] amazing
yeah I'm invested in Ben Moe so I agree
I changed my mind
okay I think open data
is gonna be amazing what do you think
open data you know about this it's like
when you just pala DS and C's and kind
of say here's all our data and I'm
thinking like if you get things like
food inspection reports the actual data
is boring but now you know where every
single restaurant is in the city by law
and I want to know where you think
that's gonna go and like I think it's
gonna be huge I think that there's a ton
of money to be made yeah I think you're
right I think countries are gonna want
you to do this I think that this is a
space that I haven't done enough
thinking on I think it's a perfect
example of something I believe in which
is in general I need to the reason
they're not gonna be speaking as much
anymore sigh I think it's time for me to
shut the [ __ ] up for a little bit I've
been talking for quite a while and I
think it's time for me to do and this is
a perfect example I'm aware of it but
I've done absolutely no homework to
really give a true answer right so I
can't answer you and that's because I've
been spending too much time speaking and
not enough time thinking and looking and
so the real answer is I haven't given it
a real thought yet and so I can't truly
answer you but I think my intuitions
like hmm you know I've got them hmm
remember that song things that make you
go mmm yeah no sorry yeah it was good um
that's C&C Music Factory [ __ ] yeah all
right thanks man
you know I'll get you know what some
emails to Gary at vaynermedia calm and
I'll send you an answer in a week sweet
hey man hey Gary my name's Jay hey CheY
Jay Jay [ __ ] sorry I thought you were
Mets Stadium yeah you talk about you
know more mom-and-pop they're kind of
going in that direction
yeah mom-and-pop skill sets sure and
you're also talking about dealing with
large corporations try to get them to
understand but you made a comment
earlier about how with the Wine Library
you couldn't ship to like Boston yeah
you know they're so puritanical and
right well Merrill big you know right
how do you kind of attack that vein of
like is these conglomerates sir you mean
like the liquor wholesaler yeah yeah how
does that fit into the equation for you
you know I have this deep dark secret
thought that I'm gonna build this
trillion dollar company and then go
after the families of everybody who was
involved in a liquor wholesale business
yes I'll help that's pretty much the
answer I mean you know it's unfortunate
I would have loved to stick and fight
that fight and I'm a big voice and I
could have helped it but unfortunately
the liquor retailers are so fragmented
and most of them think small and they're
more worried about wine libraries
shipping in they it's the same old game
they're thinking of the down side
instead of the up side it's not
different than corporations that tell me
we don't want to open us up because
people could say our products bad
well how about all the communication all
the good and so unfortunately most of us
a lot of us are wired in a way where we
look at the negative more so impossible
for example and I don't got to leave it
looks like in a second rap please I get
it you're not gonna give me another I'm
so awesome we got five more minutes yeah
you know the fact that matter is is that
I lost my train of thought but I'll
catch in a second give me one second
that shift is here and and people need
to look at the positives I for one and
blown away on how poorly human beings
are branded I think we are dramatically
underestimated and ridiculously
mispositioned
I think we are so much better than we
give each other credit for people focus
on the negatives it's really the shark
and hippo thing right sharks
those poor [ __ ] they are so brand
leapord it's me so poorly branded you
know everybody's scared of them cuz
[ __ ] Spielberg and all that [ __ ] and
everybody's scared of them right
meanwhile hippos we love them Hungry
Hungry Hippos awesome meanwhile those
[ __ ] kill way more people than sharks
it's true and I kind of think about
humans that way when I hear things like
oh don't check into places because
people gonna rob your house [ __ ] you
who's gonna rob my house you know that
you know I mean if the numbers are so
much smaller the bad things are so much
smaller than all the good that's
happening in all our interactions we are
dramatically being under appreciated
team humans
hi Gary my name is Michael Michaels loud
just as a brief aside we start with a
hug we moved to a kiss trying to
extrapolate a trajectory leaves me baby
wants about where this is going seven
minutes in heaven
you ready computer nerd I don't really
have much connection with business
people in fact I'm you know I think you
hate us exactly yeah we used to think of
them as the enemy sure in a way but I
really like what you're saying that a
lot of business people one or two of us
sighted that's what I was exactly you
just nailed it no I'd love to think that
but there's more good than bad listen
listen business people are wired in a
way that they're very you know they're
analytics driven to right they want to
make it you know here's what's cool
nobody was more business lead business
business Ben than me right I would [ __ ]
him you know my early early days I hate
to say it but I would have told you
anything about that Pinot Noir to make
sure you bought a case right and just
you know that raw business ethics but
you know what because of people can you
guys do me a favor because I love him so
[ __ ] much seriously if you are on
Twitter right now can you please add
Kastner something let's give him let's
do the same thing like at Kastner your
face is beautiful you know I know him so
much because you know when I think about
this he came in working with me and he
was after 9/11 so it's tough times so
that's why I probably had to work for
less money than you deserved at a liquor
store for a very businessí guy even
though he was a very but he's just the
best dude and he helped me look at the
world in a different way and do am i
anywhere close to where he looks the
world I'm not but allow me to look at
different things and I think for you if
we spent a weekend together man seven
minutes and our ticket you know I move
fast brother um that I think you would
look at it differently because it's it's
you know it's gonna it's one of these
great it's gonna happen anyway there's
gonna be commerce right and there's good
ways to go about it and there's bad ways
and I think in general the space that
you're all part of you're gonna be very
very proud you guys it makes me so happy
to know and I mean it and this there's
such a good vibe in this room for me in
my heart that the people in this
conference they the people sitting right
in front
you're gonna be really feeling good
about yourself in 50 60 years sitting
there you know on the lake fishing you
gonna be like I was a part of something
in a very early stages that really
really really means something this is
once again because I think we're so bad
at branding and understanding where
things go this is so much bigger than we
understand and it's gonna feel nice that
we were a part of it thank you sure man
last one
hey Gary
hey bro yeah Mike Mike yeah I really
appreciate all your insights into the
business and change and how things are
moving there but I'm curious about what
your thoughts are on social change yeah
it sort of outside of the business realm
and sure what you see developing and
what your interesting that is yes so
this is funny I was telling somebody a
story yesterday I actually showed
somebody my tax report the other day
because they called me out and said why
didn't you tweet about Haiti or this and
that and back to that rant I gave you
earlier about a hundred fans and this
and that for all my bravado and all my
promotion and all my in-your-face stuff
I'm very weird about charity and social
stuff I feel like it's the wrong thing
you know it's so I'm a backwards dude in
a lot of ways right like a lot of people
don't feel like you should talk about
your business stuff or selling but you
talk about that stuff in a weird way I'm
the reverse literally this guy was like
I invited him to Starbucks and show to
my tax return said now what [ __ ] you
know and so that felt good I think
there's a lot of good things going on in
that I have gotten somewhat active with
charity water you know Scott here's what
I think I think we're about to be in the
golden era of it you know why because I
think because of the platform the
internet and just the space and because
guys like me because influenced by guys
like Kastner and other people moved more
this way a lot of charity and a lot of
social things are gonna start looking a
lot more like business because in the
past they've been run by people that
aren't business people and the reason
charity water is dominating is because
Scott Harrison was a club promoter
entrepreneur through and through so he
understands and so I feel like we're
about to go through a golden era because
business people are gonna be making
these charity decisions not just being
on the board for an hour once a month
but actually running them and impacting
them and I think socially I also think
just the transparency that we're living
in socially is creating enormous gifts
and opportunity I just think we're all
gonna have
live a better world think about how dads
have been rebranded do you guys
recognize that golf industry is down do
you know why
forget the Tiger Woods stuff I mean
globally it's been tracking down the
golf business is soft you know why the
answer with your kids because dads are
different you got it buddy because 70 to
me I'm golfing on Saturday doing
business now me and me sure in the park
and so I cook you know I'm a bit you
know I'm all in I'm bullish on human
beings and I think this platform again
not [ __ ] Facebook or Ustream the
internet the web whatever you want to
call it has created one of the great
opportunities for enlisted there'll be
bad things I get it and one day somebody
will hijack and the whole thing will
shut down and we're all dead or whatever
I understand I get it you know net
neutrality I get it [ __ ] aliens I get
it do I think robots win yes but we
won't see it but so I get all that but
here's what I know we should be thankful
as [ __ ] because I think we've got a good
ear app yeah man thank you guys so much